this is alice it's a prototype
all-electric plane that its maker
aviation hopes will be one of the first
commercial passenger planes to take off
while there are a few companies pursuing
electric passenger planes many of them
are just at the early design stage but
when i spoke to aviation ceo he told me
that alice will be airborne for testing
sometime in the next few weeks now this
plane has had its setbacks over the
years but if it eventually gets
certified it could offer a way for the
industry to decarbonize some of the tens
of thousands of short-haul flights made
in america every year but the key word
there is some because right now battery
power has its limits so are electric
planes about to take off let's find out
okay first you might be wondering why
the planes that you fly today aren't
electric after all if we can take a
gasoline car and swap out the engine and
fuel for electric motors and batteries
to make an ev then surely we can do the
same for planes right well kinda but
also
see while there have been some
successful attempts and prototypes of
electric planes in the past even by
airbus there's a good reason why many of
the industry leaders are pursuing
hydrogen over lithium-ion batteries and
that reason is physics specifically
energy versus weight let me explain in
order to get a plane that's carrying
passengers and luggage to take off you
need energy quite a lot of in fact now
back down on the ground if our little
car here were to run out of energy it
would just come to a stop but if a plane
runs out of juice something far worse
happens
so when you fly you have to carry all
the energy you need for the whole
journey plus reserves with you as fuel
now crucially all fuel has weight and
that's where a bit of a balancing act
comes in ideally you want your fuel to
be as energy dense as possible so it
packs loads of energy for minimal
additional weight jet fuel is incredibly
energy dense at around 12 000 watt hours
per kilogram but even the latest
aviation batteries don't even come close
to the energy density of jet fuel they
pack around 1 60th of that at 200 to 220
watt hours per kilogram it's a huge
difference not everybody is an aerospace
engineer but it means you're always
carrying around a lot of weight so to
make a battery-powered plane fly you
need to rethink things like the
aerodynamics of the plane or how much
the plane weighs how many passengers it
can carry and how far it can fly and
that brings us to alice aviation say
that the plane has been designed from
the ground up to be as light and
aerodynamic as possible to try and get
the most out of those batteries there's
about 8 200 pounds of batteries in a 16
500 pound aircraft on alice the
batteries are stored in the body which
means that the wings which would
normally hold fuel can be thinner and
more aerodynamically efficient the
company has released designs for three
different configurations of alice from a
cargo plane 12 of which have been
ordered by dhl to a commuter design that
could carry nine passengers plus their
luggage nine passengers is the limit for
the number of paying passengers you can
carry on in aircraft with a single pilot
operations but this isn't the first time
the aviation which was founded in 2015
has said that alice was almost ready to
take to the skies in early 2020 the
company lost one of its initial
prototypes due to a fire in the battery
compartment which is one of the problems
with batteries they can combust that
event and having that thermal runway uh
it actually drove the development of the
safety technology that we're using and
have designed into our battery system
even if aviation conducts some test
flights soon the plane will still need
to be certified by the faa which the
company hopes will happen by 2024.
so
if alice works could that pave the way
for all planes to eventually become
battery powered in short right now
no
because regulations aren't the only
reason that alice can only carry nine
passengers the other reason is those
batteries despite all of those design
changes to try and squeeze the absolute
maximum out of those batteries alice can
still only carry 2 500 pounds for a
maximum of 440 nautical miles some point
in time on an electric airplane if you
add more batteries all they're going to
be used for is powering your aircraft to
carrier and more batteries unless
battery technology sees some huge leaps
in terms of energy density it's likely
that if battery power planes take off
they'll be limited to short trips with
handfuls of passengers and therefore
they're unlikely to displace many of the
aircraft that fly today that can carry
tens if not hundreds of passengers so
while you may be able to hop on a
battery-powered plane sometime in the
near future
it's unlikely you'll be able to go very
far on it
hey thanks for watching so do you think
battery powered planes are going to take
off let me know in the comments below
and as always if you're interested in
the future of how we might be getting
from a to b then don't forget to
subscribe see you soon
you